[Music]
hello friends and welcome to some tv
i'd like to know where we answer your
bible questions
and today we have a number of questions
coming to us and hopefully we can get
through
a few of them we want to start with the
word of prayer and ask god to send his
holy spirit to guide us
as we seek to answer these questions
from the bible
so let's pray father in heaven thank you
again for your word
thank you for the promised blessing of
your holy spirit and as we seek to dig
into
a meaning a deeper meaning of scripture
and answer some of the questions that
have come into us today we're just
praying that
our hearts will be susceptible to your
holy spirit that you'll speak to us that
you'll guide us that you'll direct us
that you'll help us to understand your
word in the way that you meant it to be
understood and we pray and ask these
things
in jesus name amen
so as you've noticed i'm by myself today
ca is still gone
uh in panama we're hoping he'll be back
soon
and pastor stephen bohr is on a
conference call a zoom
meeting for the next hour and a half so
he asked me to go ahead
and answer some of the questions that
have come in i'm going to start with a
couple
that have been sitting for a while and
hoping that we can get these answered
because i'm sure
those who sent them have been eagerly
looking for answers
there are two questions that come to us
in relationship to
creation and the creation account
the writer says i have a very technical
question about creation and the time
frame within which some remarkable
events took place
as recorded by the bible first
when was the devil and his angels hurled
down to earth
was it sometime in the years before the
creation of man or was it
after the creation of man for our
biblical record
of events our earth is some six thousand
years old well
if we go back to genesis uh and the
creation account i think we'll get a
pretty good idea
that satan was cast out of heaven before
the creation of man in fact as we read
into this a little bit we'll realize
that
this took place just before the creation
of man and the establishment
of planet earth in genesis chapter 2
god is repeating the creation story from
a different perspective
and he talks here about how he took man
and put him in the garden to address it
verse 15
and the lord god commanded the man
saying of the tree
of the garden of every tree of the
garden thou may freely eat
verse 17 but of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil thou shalt
not eat of it
for the day thou eatest thereof thou
shalt surely die
and he repeats this warning again and we
see this coming up in genesis chapter 3
the knowledge of good and evil there was
no evil
in all of god's universe before sin
intruded
and so for god to sh to warn adam about
the knowledge of good and evil and to
have a place where he could make a
choice
against god for evil would uh suggest
that rebellion apostasy had already
taken place in heaven that
satan himself had been cast out
and most probably was looking for a
dwelling place you know revelation 12
indicates that he was cast into the
earth but that's because we chose
in genesis chapter 3 to receive his
deceptive lies about god and about god's
character
and because of that because we chose
evil which was already present
in the universe which suggests clearly
that the fall the apostasy of satan had
already taken place before the creation
of man
we then allowed this earth to become his
dwelling place for these last 6 000
years i hope that helps to answer
the question the second question from
the same viewer is
this what baffles me is
natural science and fossil studies which
proves that our earth is some millions
or billions
of years old please help me unravel
this mystery well it is difficult it is
challenging for us
and i'm not a scientist and i don't
claim to have an education that can
answer this question
in the kind of detail that many would
like to hear but i just want to share
one thought with you that i think may be
helpful for you
and has been very helpful for me over
the years in relation to
the scientific evidence of fossils
and other findings in our earth that
seem to indicate that our earth is
millions and billions of years old
and it's this it's very simple if you
look
in the bible and you read the creation
account
it talks about in genesis chapter 1 and
of course genesis 2 about god creating
man
and it says of course that god put man
to sleep and took a rip from his side to
create woman
so you have god creating man from the
dust of the ground and breathing into
his nostrils the breath of life
and man becomes a living soul now
according to the bible
the day that god created adam how
old was he according to the bible he was
one day old
not even one day old he was minutes old
or hours old as soon as that breath of
life came into him
and he awakened to life even though he
was a man of full stature
some 15 feet tall even though he was
completely matured
in his symmetry adam was actually just
a few minutes old however now let me ask
you this question
if scientists were to look at adam at
that time or to examine him or to
carefully look at his
makeup and compare him perhaps with
other human beings and
and and life as we know it and and
observe the process
the science of a baby being born
and maturing and growing from from
babyhood to in
you know in infancy all the way up to
maturity how old were the
science or how old with scientists
looking at adam
on day one when he's a few minutes old
how old would they say adam was
and the answer to that is probably they
would say he was
20 or 30 or 40 years old it just depends
on
what adam looked like in his human form
the day he was created he might have
looked like he was 20 or might have
looked like he was 30.
but the point is this science
looks at the record of what god has
created in a day
and they assess it based on the evidence
that we have today rather than based on
the clear teaching of the word of god
clearly adam was only a few minutes old
when scientists come in and look at him
they
must conjecture that he is probably many
years old many times older
than what he actually is and i believe
it's the same
with science in relationship to fossils
and in relationship
to the things we see in our world today
we look at that
as evidence and we overlook the fact
that god created the world
in six literal days and when he spoke it
was
and the other aspect of this that's
important to recognize as the flood and
how that
changed everything layers were laid down
as the flood came upon this earth as the
waters
filled this earth and then of course
they
receded leaving these layers of rock and
sediment and animals
and life forms in the different layers
and one of the things that really helps
us with that is when they find
trees that are not vertical or not
horizontal but
vertical through all of those layers so
you can do a lot of research on this
you can find more answers but i think
that's a simple biblical answer
adam looked as though he were many years
old many
many years older than what he actually
was he was probably just i mean he was
just a few minutes old when god
created him all right we have another
question that's come in and this one
came in
just recently i was in my office
preparing for
this live program i'd like to know and a
friend of mine from tennessee
sent this question he sent a little text
to me and he said hello
when you have time can you give me
thoughts on luke chapter 16.
in its relationship to the parable it is
associated with
i can't make heads or tales of the
lesson christ is giving here
i get parts of it but it's still
confusing to make its application
to the christian walk i wasn't satisfied
with our commentaries on it so let me
know
thank you all right well we're going to
go to luke chapter 16
and we're going to take a look at this
challenging little story
it is a little bit challenging so let's
read through the story and then we'll
try to
look at some of the key points that are
made here in the story and
why christ is sharing it with his
disciples and the pharisees
so luke chapter 16 begin with verse one
and he said also unto his disciples
there was a certain rich man which has
a steward and the same was accused unto
him that he had wasted his goods
and he called him and he said unto him
how is it that i hear this of thee give
an account of thy stewardship
for thou mayest no longer be steward
then the steward said within
himself what shall i do for my lord
takes away from me the stewardship
i cannot dig and to beg i am ashamed i
am resolved what to do verse 4
that when i am put out of the
stewardship they may receive me into
their houses so he called
everyone verse 5 his lord's debtors and
said unto him
his lord's debtors unto him and said
unto the first how much owest thou unto
my lord and he said a hundred measures
of oil and he said
unto him take thy bill and sit down
quickly and write
fifty verse seven then he said to
another and how much owest thou
and he said a hundred measures of wheat
and he said unto him
take thy bill and write forescore and
the lord commended the unjust steward
verse 8
because he had done wisely for the
children of this world are in their
generation
wiser than the children of light and i
say unto you verse 9
make to yourselves friends of the mammon
of unrighteousness
that when you fail they may receive you
into everlasting
habitations he that is faithful in that
which is least is faithful also in much
he that is unjust in least is unjust
also
in much if therefore you have not been
faithful in unrighteous mammon
who will commit to you trust the true
riches and if you have not been faithful
in that which is another man's
who shall give you that which is your
own no servant can serve two masters for
either you will hate the one and love
the other
or else you will hold to the one and
despise the other you cannot serve god
and mammon so this is the story and
we're going to look first of all
at the context of the story then we're
going to break down the story
section by section and then we're going
to look at some key ideas that i think
will help unlock the point that is being
made here by christ first of all
the context the context of story begins
back in luke chapter 15.
it begins with jesus christ drawing near
to him publicans and sinners he he's
hanging around with the world he's
hanging around with the
the unrighteous mammon is what the king
james says people who are sinners people
that are in the world he's hanging
around them
he's drawing them and the pharisees are
murmuring against him verse two saying
this man receives sinners
and eats with them now we know why jesus
is doing this jesus is doing this
because he has an interest
in every single human being he doesn't
care if we're
self-righteous or if we're sinners or if
we are
truly honestly seeking the lord jesus
christ is seeking to break down
every barrier possible to reach people
with the good news
of his salvation the gift of salvation
to
every nation cringer tongue and people
and so jesus christ is
hanging out with the with the pharisees
the publicans and the sinners and the
pharisees don't
like it and so jesus christ begins to
give a
a a number of parables here to try to
help
them the pharisees to understand how
important it is
to reach out to the world with the
gospel and why jesus is sitting
with republicans and sinners they think
he's there because he wants an excuse
to indulge his appetite because he wants
to to
live you know loosely because he wants
to just be
able to take advantage you know or
indulge in the lust of the flesh
no not at all that's what they're
thinking because that's the way they
process but jesus
is not thinking that at all and so he
gives the parable of
the lost sheep he gives the parable of
the lost coin he gives the parable of
the prodigal son
and then we get to rev to luke chapter
where he tells a story of a certain man
and this is actually a true story it's a
story that took place
in the recent recently in that area it's
a story that
the number of the people here would be
familiar with
a steward is called to account by his
lord and the lord
hears that the steward has been
unfaithful and so the lord calls him
into account and says hey
i'm going to take the stewardship from
you now it's interesting
this lord the lower case l
gives the steward a warning he basically
tells them
you're going to lose the stewardship if
what i've heard about you is true
and so thinking about this consequence
this steward begins to wonder what he's
going to do and he thinks well i can't
work and i don't want to
beg what am i going to do i know what
i'll do
instead of indulging and giving
everything to myself
taking my lord's goods and giving them
to myself and
and planning for myself focused on
myself what i'm going to do
is i'm going to start investing in some
of these people
that owe me the the lord
owe him money i'm gonna start investing
in them and so he begins to go
and he begins to tell them hey a hundred
say fifty
um you know you you owe him this much
say it's going to be less
and we see this here in verse 6 for
example 100 measures of oil
write quickly that it's 50. and tonight
he says how much do you owe and he said
verse 7 100 measures of wheat and he
said unto him take that bill and write
four score
or 80. and then it says and here's one
of the key verses verse 8
the lord commended the unjust steward
because he had done wisely
now we need to recognize that the lord
here that's commending the unjust
steward is not the lord god of heaven
it's not the lord jesus christ
it's a lowercase l it's the same lord
that is mentioned
in verse three and the same lord that's
mentioned further down here
when he talks about how the lord is
going to take the stewardship
from him so we need to be really clear
here verse 3 is talking about the lord
of the steward
and again in verse 5
how much do you want to your lord and
again we have it in verse 7 or it's
inferred
there how much do you owe
and so verse 8 the lord the one that
is over the steward who is now
investing in these people that owe the
steward the steward and the lord money
is the one that commends the steward for
what he does
and then it goes jesus goes on to say
for the children of this world are in
their generation
wiser than the children of light and
then he says this and this is the key
verse this is the verse we have a
question about
for i say unto you make to yourselves
friends of
mammon or friends of the world or
friends of riches
of unrighteousness that when you fail
they may receive you into everlasting
habitations
now here this is what is is really
difficult for under us to understand but
here's
basically what the point that jesus is
making
and he's saying this i jesus am
investing
in the unrighteous publicans and sinners
i'm investing in them
and this steward this unfaithful steward
invested in those
people who owed the lord money even
though he did it unjustly
he was investing in them because he was
thinking in the future i can actually
receive from them if i give to them
and jesus is basically saying even
though that wasn't right for him
to be changing the bill that was owed to
his lord
even though that was unrighteous for him
to do that it was wiser for him
than the pharisees and scribes were the
pharisees and the scribes were
were unwise in the way that they were
administering god's goods in comparison
with the unjust steward
at least the unjust steward was
investing in other people
thinking about his future the scribes
and pharisees weren't doing that they
were
refusing to invest in other people and
they weren't thinking
about the consequences of that refusal
now let me share with you a couple
thoughts i think will really help us to
understand this
first of all we want to emphasize that
the worldly man
praised the sharpness of the man who had
defrauded him but the rich man's
condemnation was not the condemnation of
god and that's in christ
object lessons page 367 continuing on in
the same statement
christ did not commend the unjust
steward
but he made use of a well-known
occurrence to illustrate
the lesson he desired to teach make to
yourselves friends by means of the
moment of unrighteousness
he said that when it shall fail they may
receive you
into the eternal tabernacles or you
could say when you shall fail
because all of us are going to fail this
earth is going to fail everything is
going to fail
and so this steward his job is failing
right now and so he's investing
in these people that owe his lord money
someday this earth is going to fail and
if we're just
laying up treasures here and investing
here and putting
all that we have and spending all of our
time and focus here
when it fails we're going to be left
with nothing basically what jesus
is saying we need to be thinking about a
whole different investment
and we need to be investing in other
people and
and doing it righteously not
unrighteously investing in other people
so this steward is wiser than us because
he's investing in other people
instead of investing in himself he's
thinking about other people instead of
thinking about himself
and as he thinks about other people his
future becomes more secure
now let's follow this as we read a
little bit more in christ object lessons
where i think this becomes
even clearer the servant in the parable
had made no provision for the future
the goods entrusted to him for the
benefit of others he had used for
himself
but he had thought but he had thought
only
excuse me the goods entrusted him for
the benefit of others he'd used only for
himself he had only thought
but he had thought only of the present
when the stewardship should be taken
away from him
he would have nothing to call his own
but his master's goods were still in his
hands and he determined to use them so
as to cure
himself against future want to
accomplish this
he must work on a new plan instead of
gathering for himself
he must impart to others thus
he might secure friends who when he
should be cast out would receive him
so were the pharisees now here's where
we make the transition
to the pharisees so were the pharisees
the stewardship was soon to be taken
from them
and they were called upon to provide for
the future
only by seeking the good of others could
they benefit themselves
only by imparting god's gift to in in
the present life could they provide
for eternity do you see the parallel
crisis making here
the parallel is is that this steward
unjust as he was
thinking about the future began to
invest in others instead of keeping
everything for himself
and jesus is saying he's smarter even
his lord
commended him for thinking in a smart
way of investing in others
you guys don't even think is like that
you're just you are just thinking about
yourselves scribes and pharisees you're
not thinking
about investing in others you're
criticizing me because i'm sitting with
republicans and sinners
but i'm sitting here to invest in them
because for christ
i want that investment to come back i
want them to be in the kingdom of god
and when this earth fails i'm hoping
that they will be part of my kingdom so
i'm investing in them
you're not willing to do that because
you're only thinking of yourselves
that's where he gives the story and the
story has quite
a bang it goes on those
those who spend their lives in laying up
worldly treasures
show less wisdom less thought and care
for their eternal well-being than did
the unjust steward for his earthly
support less wise than the children of
this world and their generation are
these professed children of light
the these are they of whom the prophet
declared in his vision
of the great judgment day a man shall
cast the idols of his silver and the
idols of his gold
which they made each one for himself to
worship to the moles and to the bats
to go into the clefts of the rocks into
the tops of the ragged rocks
for fear of the lord and for the glory
of his majesty when he arises to
shake terribly the earth so what is god
wanting us to do what what is the point
that god is making here in the context
of this story god is saying to the
pharisees and scribes and there are many
of us
who are scribes and fairies today
pharisees today he's saying listen
you are only thinking about yourselves
and you're only laying up treasure for
yourselves
and when this earth fails you'll be left
with nothing
look at this parable of this story look
at the unjust steward
he realized that he was going to be left
with nothing and when he came to that
realization he started investing
in people instead of just investing
himself now it wasn't
right for him to do that and god was not
commending him
the lord of the steward commanded him
because the lord of the steward was
thinking
wow that was a sharp that was a smart
thing for him to do
but god isn't commending god isn't
saying that it's right for us
to do what the unjust doer did but what
god is saying is
it is right for us to stop investing in
ourselves
and start investing in other people
that's what jesus was doing with the
scribes and the pharisees
or excuse me with republicans and
sinners the scribes and the pharisees
were criticizing him
because he was investing in publicans
and sinners and that is what god is
calling us to do
god wants us to invest in people and not
in ourselves
and that's the point of this story
that's where we see the story
being used by christ to commend this
unjust steward because he began to
invest in others instead of investing in
himself
and we need to take a lesson there let's
start investing in others god has given
us
means he's he's blessed us with
prosperity
a lot of times we think about ourselves
sometimes just about our immediate
family and we don't think about those
who
are poor in in less uh
in in in difficult situations in other
countries
they're impoverished they have a hard
time getting an education they have a
hard time putting food on the table they
have a hard time paying their bills
they're struggling from day to day and
we have
more than enough clothes to wear food to
eat
covering over us a house to live in we
have luxuries
beyond and we want to to change and
upgrade and put money into
stuff that that could go easily to
helping other people
simply get by get an education better
their lives
and so this is what christ is calling us
to do he's calling us
to stop investing in ourselves and start
investing in others
and it's it's a challenge for many of us
it's a challenge we live
in this earth today to stop looking at
the joneses and
comparing ourselves with our neighbors
and others who have all this stuff and
start investing in people
which is an eternal investment that will
come back to us
in eternity so i hope that answers the
question
and gives at least a good perspective
basically we need to share
we need to give to the world just like
christ gave republicans and sinners
and we need to stop hoarding for
ourselves and start
giving for god all right we have another
question here and i think we have a few
minutes left so we'll try to answer this
one last question
here's the question pastor is there
anything wrong with sporting
activities like soccer
well the bible tells us in 1st timothy
chapter 4 verse 8
for physical training is of some value
but godliness has value for all things
holding promise for both the present
life and the life to come
that's first timothy chapter four verse
eight and it's the new international
version
physical training is of some value so
this scripture
uh is basically comparing physical
training
and godliness and it indicates that you
know sporting activities
have some value that's what the
scripture is telling us they have some
value
for example they give us a
physical exercise that the body needs to
stay in shape
they offer a needed break from mental
activity physical exercise
like sports can help us vent stress they
can it can help us
paint the energy of youth
yet paul goes on to say to timothy
when we compare this physical training
with godliness physical exercise is
actually less
valuable you know godliness is much more
valuable
because godliness helps us in this life
as well as in
the life to come so i would say it's
like comparing
sporting activities and godlinesses like
comparing
twenty dollars to a million dollars you
know
uh 20 is valuable right but if we have
to choose between the two we would be
much wiser
to take the million dollars so so in my
personal life
um sporting activities have some value
that's what the scripture is saying
the the the physical training is of some
value sporting activities have some
value
i lift weights uh i play tennis and by
the way that the the friend that just
sent that question in earlier
is one of the guys that got me into
lifting weights and getting me physical
and i'm going to challenge him right now
if he's still listening
yeah we got to get those weights going
we got to get physical and get strong
and stay strong
especially as we get older i lift
weights i play tennis i swim
i spend time in physical activities
because i know it's going to benefit me
and that's what the scripture is saying
it's good it benefits us
it benefits our bodies it benefits our
minds
and but i spend even more time
exercising godliness you see physical
training is of some value but
godliness has value for all things
i love that because i know that
godliness is going to
to benefit me now and eternally you know
so
so i can be in the garden working i can
go out in nature and take a walk
i can be cutting wood for heat and that
has benefit both for physical exercise
and getting the weeds out of my garden
and for getting heat into the house
and going out in nature for a walk or i
can be lifting weights or playing some
tennis
or going for a swim all of that is going
to benefit me it's going to
benefit me physically it's going to help
my me mentally it's going to help me
deal with stress but godliness godliness
is like
a million dollars compared to a 20 bill
when it comes to physical exercise
so the question was is there anything
wrong with sporting activities like
soccer
only if that completely saturates
our focus on godliness if our sports and
our interest in sports
takes the place of that which god wants
us to focus on
yep i would say there's a problem but if
we put it in its proper place like a 20
bill compared to a million dollars oh we
need physical exercise and it can be
very good for you so get your physical
exercise
and make sure you focus on the word of
god
[Music]
you